adding her own flowers to a garden that
already holds so much meaning for so
many the duchess of cambridge was here
to support the families who now have a
special place to mourn and reflect
something prince william spoke of in a
deeply personal way as someone who lives
with his own grief
i also know that what often matters most
to the bereaved is that those we have
lost
are not forgotten
there is comfort in remembering
in acknowledging that
while taken
horribly soon
they lived
they changed our lives
they were loved
and they are loved
22 people were killed by a terrorist who
attacked manchester arena five years ago
this memorial in the city center is a
permanent testimony to their lives and
the design was chosen by their families
next to each name um there's a little
bronze heart and a cap and underneath
there there's a memory capsule and each
family has left either a letter or
memento
or something you know about their loved
one which is personal to them
i put a cigarette in the lighter in for
him because he likes to smoke
i bought a boneville chocolate because
the only
when he ate sweets that's the only thing
yet
junetron says this is a spiritual place
a place she feels close to her son i was
stood looking through the fencer and i
just felt and
i just prep a presence and all i heard
was i'm here ma'am
and it was philip i know it was philip
people would think i'm not as good
and it was him
the memorial is called the glade of
light
the stones are made of white marble and
arranged to form the shape of a halo
ring there are also different kinds of
plants that will flower all year round
to keep this place feeling alive
it's here for the future generations as
well you know in 20 years time when
people that are directly evolved
involved
are not around quite the same you know
everybody can still see the memorial and
still remember what happened and
just just think about
life and
how things can change
[Music]
a lasting tribute to those who are gone
those whose lives will never be the same
again and a community scarred but united
against hate becky cottrell sky news
manchester